vamos a revisar la integral de línea f
punto n de s de aquí que tenemos aquí
porque quiero estar seguro de que
tengamos el concepto correcto y la
verdad es que no fui tan claro en el
vídeo anterior y en este vídeo quiero
ser más preciso y de hecho utilizaré
unidades para que realmente entendamos
qué es lo que está pasando y de hecho he
dibujado aquí una trayectoria se y la
recorremos en sentido contrario a las
manecillas del reloj muy bien este
digamos nuestra orientación positiva que
tenemos de esta curva y también he
pintado en algunos puntos cómo se vería
a lo mejor el campo vectorial
efe que de hecho aquí tenemos expresado
y ahorita vamos a explicar más entonces
en cualquier punto del espacio está
definido nuestro campo vectorial efe no
sabemos exactamente cómo sea pero nos va
a interesar ver cómo se comporta justo
en la frontera de nuestra curva muy bien
y también tenemos el vector normal
unitario n que en cualquier punto de la
curva
se comporta de forma ortogonal a la
misma aunque entonces en cada punto de
la curva este vector n es ortogonal en
ponerlo de este lado el vector n es
ortogonal a la curva a la curva c muy
bien y bueno realmente yo decía que la f
era un campo vectorial
efe era una especie de velocidad pero
faltaba algún detalle faltaba un detalle
porque si queríamos ver la cantidad de
materia que era la que iba saliendo de
esta curva se por cada segundo
en realidad necesitábamos definir
también algo que fuera una densidad de
masa y aquí es como como he utilizado
esta esta función escalar lo que depende
de xy de iu es decir en cada punto del
plano tendremos la densidad de este de
este de más en cada punto de plano
entonces esta función de aquí que era lo
que realmente faltaba agregar en el
vídeo anterior es la densidad de masa
la densidad de densidad de más ok y eso
lo agregamos porque queremos hablar de
la cantidad de materia que sale es
verdad y bueno ahora aquí tenemos
tenemos que el campo vectorial que está
formado por una función m que multiplica
al vector unitario y y una función n que
multiplica el vector unitario jota esto
de aquí representa esencialmente la
velocidad que llevan las partículas en
cada punto del espacio o que cada punto
del espacio se le asigna un vector
velocidad y hablamos de la velocidad
porque en sí las funciones m y n son
funciones escalares que al multiplicarlo
por un vector pues nos da un vector pero
esta parte de aquí cada uno de estos lo
que me está diciendo es una cantidad de
rapidez qué tan rápido van las las
partículas y por supuesto m me está
hablando de la rapidez que llevan pero
en la dirección del vector y es decir en
la direc
horizontal y n me está dando la rapidez
que llevan pero en la dirección vertical
verdad que es la dirección del vector j
entonces vamos a hacer un poquito de
análisis de las de las
de las unidades que llevan cada una de
estas por ejemplo la densidad la
densidad siempre es la misma que es la
masa entre el área
massa sobre área
aunque es la masa que hay por unidad de
área y que esto se traduce en no sé si
le ponemos algunas unidades por ejemplo
podríamos hablar de kilogramos sobre
metros cuadrados muy bien y la velocidad
en sí lo que es la rapidez la rapidez
la rapidez lleva ciertas unidades que
esencialmente es distancia entre el
tiempo verdad ya esas son son detalles
físicos clásicos de cómo calculamos la
velocidad y la distancia pues tendrá
unidades de longitud que pueden ser
metros y el tiempo pues serán segundos
por ejemplo muy bien entonces si
nosotros queremos ahora entender bien
las unidades de nuestra efe pues vamos a
distribuir esta multiplicación es decir
vamos a multiplicar row por cada una de
estas dos funciones entonces ya no voy a
escribir que ferro me llene dependen de
xy de yeso queda ya muy claro sólo es
para ahorrarme espacio y demás pero efe
lo podría yo escribir como la función lo
que multiplica a m que multiplica a m
por i
la función nuevamente rojo porque esto
lo distribuimos por el la función n que
multiplica al vector j entonces lo que
tendríamos que hacer es qué pasa con las
unidades de esta multiplicación y
esencialmente como m y n tienen la misma
las mismas unidades van a quedar todo en
las mismas unidades muy bien de hecho ro
roth tiene unidades de masa en sobre
área que es la las unidades de densidad
que son kilogramos sobre metro cuadrado
muy bien y vamos a multiplicar por m que
m es una rapidez y tiene unidades de
metros sobre segundo
entonces aquí son metros sobre segundo y
si hacemos este análisis dimensional
podemos cancelar un metro con uno de
estos metros y nos queda kilogramos
sobre metro por segundo entonces estas
unidades que son un poquito raras es lo
que nos resulta de hacer esta
multiplicación de robert por el vector
verde que tenemos aquí ahora bien si
nosotros nos vamos a lo que es la
integral de línea tenemos nuestro campo
vectorial efe que ya sabemos las
unidades que va que lleva en cada en
cada acorde de coordenada y ahora
hacemos el producto punto con el vector
en entonces no sé por ejemplo fijémonos
aquí en este punto aquí tenemos como
apunta el vector f
aquí tendremos el vector normal unitario
y lo que nos está diciendo el producto
punto de esto es esencialmente cuál es
la componente que debe llevar el vector
normal para ir formando nuestro nuestro
vector del campo vectorial verdad es
decir es
la magnitud que lleva el vector normal
para ir generando el vector del campo
vectorial muy bien entonces como esto
realmente solo me está diciendo es
esencialmente la magnitud que lleva a un
vector con respecto al otro
entonces las unidades se preservan
verdades son las mismas unidades
entonces si estas unidades si estas
unidades iban en kilogramos sobre metro
por segundo cuando multiplicamos por de
ese perdón por poder efe llevaba estas
unidades kilogramos sobre metros por
segundo cuando hacemos el producto punto
con n se queda con las mismas unidades
ahora sí vamos a ver qué ocurre cuando
nosotros multiplicamos por este de ese
que si recordamos de ese no es otra cosa
más que un diminuto un
infinitesimalmente pequeño el cambio en
la longitud de la curva muy bien
entonces en realidad como estamos
hablando de longitud esto lleva a una
una unidad de longitud que pueden ser
los metros verdad entonces si queremos
ver
las unidades que lleva ya toda esta
multiplicación tenemos que hacer el
producto de estas unidades por metros
entonces tenemos kilogramos kilogramos
sobre metro por segundo
y ahora multiplicamos por las unidades
de bs que son metros entonces si hacemos
esto se cancelan los metros y esto
cuadra muy bien con la intuición que
teníamos en el vídeo anterior que son
kilogramos por segundo esto esto me está
diciendo cuál es la masa que va saliendo
en cada punto por segundo verdad ahora
bien que si estamos integrando a lo
largo de toda una curva en realidad
estamos sumando sumando todas estas
cantidades y si sumamos la cantidad de
masa que va saliendo por por segundo
entonces estamos teniendo toda la masa
que sale a través de la curva por unidad
de tiempo muy bien entonces las unidades
las unidades que llevan está integral
tenemos que la integral sobre la curva
de f punto n de s ok esto me está
diciendo que es nos está midiendo la
masa que es el que sale
que sale de la curva oa través de la
curva déjenme ponerlo así a través de la
curva
a través de la curva c
por segundo por segundo muy bien y de
hecho vimos una equivalencia en el vídeo
anterior de esta integral con otra que
era el teorema de la divergencia verdad
que esta esta integral era equivalente a
la integral sobre toda la región que
encierra la curva de la divergencia del
campo vectorial
efe por una diferencial de área verdad
y la divergencia la divergencia es
esencialmente por definición la derivada
parcial de f con perdón no no de vecino
de la primera coordenada que es m con
respecto a x
y de hecho no es esto verdad porque efe
es roboré entonces aquí va un roe por m
aunque es la derivada de esto con
respecto a x más la derivada de la
segunda de la segunda componente que es
rob por n respecto ai ok y cuál es la
unidad de todo esto
esto tiene unidades de la siguiente
forma esto de aquí pues ro m tiene
unidades kilogramos sobre metros por
segundo y si estamos dividiendo por una
unidad de longitud porque estamos
variando la cantidad x que que si
vayamos x es movernos en esta dirección
y es longitud entonces tendremos aquí
que dividir sobre metros que simplemente
se reduce a kilogramos sobre metros
cuadrados por segundo
y esto pasa igual con esto ahora si
estamos multiplicando por una
diferencial de área y la unidad de las
diferenciales de área pues pueden ser
metros cuadrados entonces esto lo
multiplicamos por metros cuadrados
y se cancelan para dejarnos simplemente
kilogramos sobre segundo y si estamos
sumando sobre toda la región se
conservan estas mismas unidades así que
espero esto haya tenido sentido para ti
sobre cómo conceptualizar la función
vectorial
efe si si te confundió mucho oa lo mejor
te gustan más las aplicaciones o más
bien si no te gustan las aplicaciones
entonces trata de hoy de ignorarlo
supongo digo al menos para mí esto me
ayudó a tener una idea mucho más fuerte
de lo que el vector
efe podría representar